what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday we got the first
official teaser trailer for venom let
there be carnage and it did not
disappoint it showed us
carnage like i said yesterday i was a
little worried they wouldn't but
luckily they did i personally liked the
trailer and if you liked it or you
didn't like it let me know why in the
comments down below
now there was a lot that happened in
this trailer yesterday but there are a
few main points that are going to have
some significant
impacts on the future of the sp umc the
sony picture universe of
marvel characters and the mcu spider-man
section not the entire mcu but just the
mcu that spider-man exists in which i'll
explain
in a bit but today i really want to talk
about these main points and talk about
the possibility
of a setup for spider-man 4
involving tobey maguire this has been a
report
rumor for some time now and i want to
dive into it and talk about how venom
let there be carnage could set this up
venom 2 combined with everything that
we're going to see in the spider verse
that's coming up in spider-man no way
home
could very much set us up for a
spider-man 4. and we're already starting
to kind of see some of the evidence for
this
in the teaser trailer in the trailer for
morbius and of course from all of the
reports from spiderman no way home
so let's break it down but quick
reminder about my stormbreaker giveaway
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel and cosmic culture
details in the description down below
now the first thing to acknowledge about
the venom 2 trailer is the stan
lee cameo and mrs chan store if you
missed it when venom says hi to mrs chan
when he brings out his tentacle he slaps
a magazine and it's stan lee
gotta recognize stan the man but here's
the big conspiracy theory that everybody
is talking about
in this trailer we see the daily bugle
in one scene eddie brock is going over a
bunch of different papers and we see the
daily bugle on his computer in the
background
and then when we see steven graham's
character which has been revealed to be
detective
mulligan we see that he is reading the
daily bugle and here's where things
start to get really really interesting
this daily bugle is seemingly the exact
same daily bugle from the sam
raimi spider-man trilogy if you compare
the two logos they are
exactly the same like really exactly the
same
as you can see here so of course people
are starting to talk about how this
could actually be the sam raimi universe
specifically the sony picture universe
of marvel characters could still be
that same universe where toby maguire
exists and i love where everybody's
head's at i would
absolutely love for this to be the case
but
it's not at least it really doesn't seem
like it could be because
like my buddy chris said over at cosmic
culture we already had
a venom and an eddie brock specifically
in the sam raimi universe in spider-man
3. so
this venom and eddie brock can't really
be in the samurai universe because there
already was a venom and eddie brock
now don't let that get you down in hopes
of a spider-man 4 with tobey maguire
because there is still a possibility
that it could happen
and there is a little bit of evidence
suggesting that
it might let's first start off by
talking about the reports of spider-man
4 and toby maguire
actually staying kind of in the mcu for
a little bit
i think most people know by now that
spider-man no way home the next
spider-man film with tom holland
is very heavily reported to be a
spider-verse
multiverse film with tobey maguire
spider-man showing up and andrew
garfield spider-man showing up doctor
strange is going
to be one of the main characters of the
movie and spider-man no way home is
going to lead directly
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of
madness so clearly the multiverse is
going to be kind of a prominent part of
no way home but of course the biggest
news is the return of tobey maguire and
andrew garfield as their respective
spider-man
and according to geekocitymag.com they
said that they've heard talks about
tobey maguire spider-man actually
continuing on
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness now as far as the story goes of
why they would do this there are ways
that make sense if tobey maguire
spider-man
finds himself in the main mcu timeline
with tom holland spider-man
he may not be able to get back that's
where doctor strange could come into
play and that's where we could see him
appear
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness because he would need doctor
strange to get back to his universe
then we have another report actually
several reports talking about how there
could be a spider-man 4
and this could be starring toby maguire
spider-man a lot of outlets have been
reporting this but i believe
it was giant freaking robot who were the
first to do so and this would be
incredibly insane
and awesome if this happened and my
buddy greg at the real rejects was
talking about how venom let there be
carnage could
actually set up spider-man 4 but then he
thought about the fact that
venom let there be carnage can't be in
the same reimu universe because of eddie
brock however
i don't think that really matters
because right now we are in a time
of the multiverse sony spider-man
universe
is most likely going to be affected by
the multiverse in spider-man no way home
now we don't really know the full
details of the deal between
sony and disney slash marvel but from
what we've heard
they made a deal to where spider-man
could appear in the sp
umc and some of the spumc characters
could appear
in the mcu as long as it's in a
spider-man film
and a spider-man film only so venom in
theory could appear in a spider-man film
but he couldn't appear in an iron man
film or captain america film captain
marvel
only spider-man and there is proof like
i mentioned that toby maguire spider-man
could
be getting set up right now in the sp
umc
many of you know and have probably heard
me talk about spider-man being
in the morbius trailer well kind of he's
on the wall
and over him the word murderer now of
course we're thinking that this could be
tom holland spider-man because of the
fact that it has the word murderer over
him and people think he murdered
mysterio however
the spider-man that we actually see here
is the sam raimi spider-man aka tobey
maguire
so he could actually already exist in
this universe
and how is that possible well the same
way that he could actually appear in the
mcu
the multiverse you have to keep in mind
that sony really really wants to be a
part of the mcu and they really want to
use tom holland's spider-man
in their films in the spumc and they're
already using characters that were in
spider-man
in their own universe vulture was seen
in the morbius trailer as well and of
course he's in the mcu
so we're already seeing the crossover
here and part of that crossover could be
toby maguire spider-man in this universe
now we don't really have any details
about what spider-man 4 could be
or which universe it could take place in
because sony does have the rights to
toby maguire spider-man
disney and sony have only talked about
and made deals about rights for tom
holland spider-man now of course we
don't know the ins and outs of any deal
that they may have going on right now
but it would be kind of cool to have
another tom holland spider-man movie and
then at the same time
another toby maguire spider-man movie
and this maybe could kind of be the
bridge between the two universes because
toby maguire spider-man is going to be
in no way home and it seems like he
exists somewhat in the sp umc
so maybe in no way home as the universes
kind of start to fall apart and kind of
start to collide with each other which
is why the other spider-man will be in
the film
maybe they'll start to explain what all
is happening maybe toby maguire's
spider-man does decide to go back but
he ends up in the wrong universe he ends
up in the universe where we have tom
hardy's eddie brock
then maybe we could get a decent venom
versus spider-man fight between tom
hardy
and toby maguire who knows what could
happen the possibilities are really
really limitless for this and i actually
do hope this will happen
if the reports about spider-man 4 are
true and if this really is toby maguire
spider-man in the morbius trailer we
could be getting tobey maguire
spider-man in the sp umc
and the merger of universes could
explain why the daily bugle is
exactly the same after all we've seen
jjj
and spider-man far from home in the
post-credits scene however his daily
bugle seems to be
a little bit different so it's clearly
from a different universe so the fact
that the daily bugle logo
in venom let there be carnage is the
exact same logo as the spider-man
sam raimi tobey maguire trilogy is good
evidence that it could be the same
universe
not the original universe of tobey
maguire but perhaps
a merged universe there truthfully is so
much that could happen so let me know
what you think about this
in the comments down below do you like
this idea of venom let there be carnage
possibly setting up tobey maguire
spider-man 4 if so how would you do it
let me know down below and don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all of the latest spider-man
and venom news don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof